welcome to this video playing Alexa with
black yeah we have a history in the NIMS
oh I thought he played the classical but
it doesn't it was some I have some kind
of some kind of memory that I have
played him before I definitely have but
I mean yeah I'm plated before in the
NIMS oh ok that's an interesting um
approach that he went for here with this
early queen d 3 I went to create the
ideas that I have the opportunity to go
back to f8 in one move sometimes you
have to invest two moves to do that
Bishop e7 and then Bishop evade I really
want to fianchetto here and so this is
what happens here Bishop g7 yeah I guess
so taking on d5 is not very dangerous
yes he got some pressure they on d5 now
interesting
if I go nite c7 here special g5 this is
a bit a bit annoying yeah I wonder if
he's really threatening something on d5
there is some person counter-attacking
possibilities on d 42 quite often I can
just takes you three actually and i
think i'm going to do that let's do this
keep it simple Knight a5 try to take
that Bishop
interesting cam to take or not to take
Bishop d7 attending Bishop c6 looks
better I mean you cannot move that
Bishop on b3 and the bishop c6 coming
cannot really be answered by d 5 because
of the Hanging Rock on a one so I moved
the Queen I also have the move B 5 which
is kind of interesting yeah let's do it
that's an interesting move after c5 I
have Bishop c6 which I like and yeah I
can also take and Bishop c6 I think I
started with the move and I would love
to take on b3 and play a five that would
be really nice so Queen g7 okay I'm
taking this and now let's March the a
poner yes I don't really think that this
is so dangerous a porn should be should
be worth something okay um i wonder if i
should go queen d 5 or not quindi five i
also have aged six in this position yeah
this is actually a good move i will
leave age six and then g5 so that good
yeah that's probably good just prevent
everything
yeah so f6 on or anything better let's
go f6 yeah all the other one I mean f
takes that opens up the bishop yeah
let's do that that must be better open
up the bishop so the only question is
can you play d5 sometime or not if not
i'm just really clearly better maybe he
can but
and I've got the a porn and and two
bishops
germ it looks nice but how do I win
actually how do i make substantial
progress don't see it at the moment
Queen Elsa known well now I have queen d
5 then I can possibly enter let's do
that ask questions later
yeah something I queen bee three us or
something like that might be might be on
the cards also ruka three hmm ok that
looks kind of passive can I do something
aggressive here md5 and something like
this won't be good but I don't see how
it will work this may be Hokage 3 where
this is now threatened ruga three
does not win unfortunately rook f3 I
don't see at least how key
so e5 or not I still get three it's not
working I don't I don't know Kennedy
High morning yeah hey I know well I'm
not sure really if taking was good
you can GS rookie 7 some some stupid
trick yeah check
Jay I don't see a win yay unfortunately
maybe there is simply none okay foo
gauge flow is really just a check
unfortunately
check yeah we can play Knight shags
check no okay yeah I screwed the lag
resigns what was of course completely
outplayed here but I I didn't find a way
to put him away this is this is probably
just a win but it's difficult throw with
no time and no time had two minutes not
playing well I mean it is really just a
win but how do you put him away I mean
this this whole idea is kind of weird so
anyway so this is right this and this
now how do I win it's a minus 3 position
push-up d5 hmm don't quite get it what
is the point Bishop to c4 or something
this is not working right now it is
working I didn't see a win here a queen
edge frights winning okay because I can
do this okay yeah it's pretty clear that
there should have been a win because why
its position was so terrible that there
should be something I didn't see it here
I can take and why this falling apart
and because this is also hanging after
yet deliberately miss places night to
see one there really should be something
i didn't i didn't see I mean I saw okay
three but what I didn't see us I only
looked at stuff like that and it's not
working Queen h4 is winning he cannot he
cannot prevent this
and then I came in did still we should
be three is also winning completely and
what am I doing here am I just totally
blind or what sorry this is just winning
of course takes jack's and I'm
everything up it's just very stupid now
and now I now he Chad he got back in the
game still supposed to be a draw and now
Queen f5 is winning again Wow yeah okay
whatever 20 seconds or so and I'm
technically not good Queen fi if he
doesn't even have a square I mean
where's he going like here check and
winning the Queen and three check yeah
no no I'm finally lost but ok here by
here I know it was clear that I would
lose on time yeah not in good shape in
this game I'm satisfied with with this I
mean it was was a very very clear game
here but I was really sometimes nowhere
spent a time on this is a couple of
seconds this is ok I was quick enough
here and this yeah Here I am Here took
like 30 seconds for that move this is
not really working right yeah I had seen
this that this is not really I mean okay
this is good for black but it's not like
a direct winning i'm looking for direct
wins here Queenie force even the best
mover just have to play rogue f3 and I
didn't see anything and then decided to
retreat
yeah and just it's just we'll get three
ah anyway thanks for watching